[Music]
good morning John
on have you seen this in case you
haven't I wanted to bring it to your
attention there was a young nerdfighter
in the Apple's Indiana who went to get
the book that you signed and she
recorded her experience and she was very
excited and they also kind of experience
the awesome of this video in an unusual
way first I want to say that I have
permission of the person who made this
video to use this second I want to say
that I'm in no way making fun of her I'm
a little bit in awe of her actually and
I wanted to experience the awesome of
nerdfighteria in a different way and
then I wanted to let you all experience
the awesome that I experienced through
the way that I experienced it and that
is what is about to be shown to you I
hope that you enjoy it you may want to
turn your speaker's down a little bit
sorry if the camera is shaking but right
now I'm like speeding to try and pick up
the book and I'm gonna try and get
it's like JJ's crippled thank you very
much to Marion for letting me use that
I've obviously changed clothes since I
made the beginning brothers video and
you can subscribe to her channel right
here hey isn't that pretty cool yeah
John I hope you appreciate how much you
are loved in this world I love you the
nerdfighters love you we all love you I
can't imagine anyone having that
reaction when going to Eko geek no not
really
nerdfighters I have it on good authority
that you'll see me performing a song
about Star Trek in the next week or so
and John I have it on pretty good
authority that I will see you this
weekend
Marian says subscribe